So thinking back to our case study, if
instead of subtracting this quantity 3w +
12n, we wanted to add it, it would
effectively be the same as, for example,
getting another three orders for wiper
blades and another 12 orders for nozzles.
So, we would be adding new orders to the
original number of orders that he had. And
therefore he would make more money in the
end. We know that some of that money would
come from the wiper blade orders, and some
of it would also come from the nozzles. So
we want to add both those quantities to
the original expression. So, that means
that both of the terms, 3w and 12n. Should
be positive. So the answer is 3w plus 12n.
So you can see the difference here between
having a negative sign, or a minus sign,
in front of something inside parentheses
versus having a plus sign in front of
something inside parentheses. The minus
sign up here ends up applying to both
terms that were inside the parentheses,
but down here. We didn't actually change
the sign of either term that is in the
parenthesis. Keep this in mind as we move
forward.